to us he's Jimmy at sac headquarters
he's Brigadier General James Stewart
ladies and gentlemen to present the
cinematography Awards one of the
all-time great stars a distinguished
performer a responsible American James
Stewart's
the nominees for the best achievement in
cinematography of a black-and-white
picture are George Wolsey for the
balcony
Lucien Ballard for the caretakers James
Wang Chao for HUD Ernest Haller for
lilies of the field milton Krasner or
love with a proper stranger and the
winner is James Wong ha
my throat's dry I got butterflies but I
want to thank mr. ripp for give me the
opportunity the photograph HUD a
wonderful crew from Paramount Studios
and all the members of the Motion
Picture Academy thank you
the nominees for the best achievement in
cinematography or the color picture are
Leon sham Roy for the carton Liang Shan
Roy for Cleopatra
gee that's five years out of a man's
life right there
ah William H Daniels milton Krasner
Charles Lang jr. and Joseph Lachelle for
How the West was won
Joseph Michelle for our melodies and
Ernest Lazlo for its mad mad mad mad
world
the winner is Leon Shama Roy for clear
pepper
before I accept this award I must pay
homage to my American crew and my
Italian crew who was so dedicated to the
completion is pictured thank you very
much